- [Malala] So, here I
stand, one girl among many.
I speak not for myself,
but for those without voice can be heard.
♫ I can't keep quiet, no oh oh oh oh oh oh
♫ A one woman riot, oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
♫ I can't keep quiet
♫ For anyone
♫ Anymore
♫ 'Cause no one knows me no one ever will
♫ If I don't say something,
take that dry blue pill
♫ They may see a monster,
they may run away
♫ But I have to do this
♫ I can't keep quiet, no oh oh oh oh oh oh
♫ Oh I can't keep quiet,
no oh oh oh oh oh oh
♫ A one woman riot, oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
♫ Oh I can't keep quiet
♫ Let it out, let it out, let it out now
♫ There'll be someone who understands
♫ Must be someone who'll understand
♫ Let it out, let it out, let it out now
♫ There'll be someone who understands
♫ Oh I can't keep quiet
♫ Let it out, let it out, let it out now
♫ I can't keep quiet, ooh
♫ No, I won't keep quiet
- [Women] Together we are strong!
Together we are strong!